[Musique]
dernière dépense de 2021 au marché de
noël de lille dans le nord de la france
la ville se situe tout près de la
frontière avec la belgique mais depuis
vingt ans plus de problème de conversion
ici on paie avec une monnaie unique on
peut avoir de la famille de l'autre côté
où on peut travailler de l'autre côté si
on devait changer tous les tous les
jours deux monnaies ce serait compliqué
si aujourd'hui les transactions se font
beaucoup par carte bancaire 10 millions
d'européens transporte toujours d euros
dans leur porte monnaie ces billets ont
fait leur apparition le 1er janvier 2002
moi le petit bonnet le week-end le même
pendant 14 heures ils piquent propre et
gratte poil cet entrepreneur canadien
qui fait des affaires depuis plus de 20
ans en france se souvient bien de cet
important changement ça a duré pendant
plusieurs années pour s'être limmat et
c'est pour ça que dans des magasins on
est obligé de mettre en français et en
euros pour expliquer aux gens dont tu es
envie d'afficher les deux prix sa
demande est quand même une grosse une
grosse adaptation et la mise en place
d'outils comme des convertisseurs comme
des étiquettes de pour eux mais afficher
les prix en euros et en francs pour que
le grand public se l'approprient à la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
lille olivier ccoty portait le nom de
monsieur euros dans l'année qui a
précédé la transition il a organisé de
nombreux ateliers pour épauler les
commerçants de la région il y avait
quand même un certain nombre de
commerçants sur l'île qui qui accepte et
les francs belges ça le rend pas même
facilité les choses de ne plus avoir à
traiter ces deux monnaies d'avoir deux
fonds de caisse de devoir après aller à
la banque déposé les francs belges avec
les conversions les taux de change et
c'est en 2002 l'arrivée de l'euro dans
12 pays du continent suscitait
fascination et inquiétude aujourd'hui
intégré dans le quotidien de centaines
de millions d'européens la monnaie
unique ça tire toujours certaines
critiques je continue à comparer les
prix avec avant et
je trouve que ça sacrément augmenter
quand même certains secteurs ont
anticipé sur le gel pour augmenter un
petit peu leur prix quelque temps avant
l'adoption de l'euro dans nos poches
sept économistes rappellent que les prix
avaient été gelés dans les six mois
entourant l'arrivée de l'euro selon lui
l'impact de la devise sur l'inflation en
général a été limité il y avait ces
critères d'entrée dans la zone euro il
était crucial pour les états membres de
l'union européenne adoptant l'euro que
ça ne provoque pas un choc économique
vingt ans après la mise en circulation
des premiers billets l'euro est
maintenant la monnaie officielle d'une
vingtaine de pays la zone pourrait
s'élargir ces prochaines années
la croatie et la bulgarie aimerait
adopter la devise il si raphaël bouvier
auclair radio canada